you don't have someone at 35 doesn't  mean you keep going to 60 and 70. again  going to extremes i'm 50. that's not  extreme no but you keep mentioning six  talking to your mic talking about you  keep mentioning 60 70. that's the  extreme from 35. but that's because you  don't you don't go from you haven't  mentioned okay a woman at 40.  you're jumping you're jumping years  that's what i'm saying i'm saying just  because my point is to begin with just  because you're 35 and you're single  doesn't mean you'll be single at 40 at  60 at 70. but the problem is at 35  you've lost all the things that men  value that that's the problem because  men men value femininity fertility and  they value youth so you can't say you're  youthful when you're almost halfway  through your life like  you can't say you're fertile when you're  you're you're about to have geriatric  pregnancy so it's like and you look  worse than you did it at 25 right so the  way you're thinking is like a woman